season five has arrived in Apex legends
and there are some big changes beyond
just new legend lobha here's all the
important stuff from the patch notes
lobha is new to the game but she's far
from the only legend with new tricks
mirage is getting a really big buff
which should totally change the meta for
his character now when you release a
decoy you can press the button again to
have it mimic every move Mirage makes
before this the decoy simply ran forward
in a straight line the same goes for
mirages ultimate now all of those decoys
will mimic his moves to his passive also
gets some special treatment you still
cloak when you get knocked down but now
you'll also cloak when responding at a
beacon or reviving a teammate and they
get the cloaking to what's more mirages
bamboozle line will play when a decoy is
destroyed instead of when it gets
deployed which you know does make a lot
more sense now let's talk lobha you
probably know all about her by now but
if not here's the important stuff her
tactical ability is called burglars best
friend and it lets her throw her
bracelet and teleport to wherever it
lands making it a great ambush tool her
passive eye for quality lets her spot
epic and legendary loot through walls
then there's her ultimate black market
boutique lobha plants her staff in the
ground which pings all loot in the area
everyone on the team can then check the
staff to see a menu similar to a death
box listing all the good stuff nearby
each squad member can then take two
pieces of gear for themselves
instantly transferring them to their
inventory other legends have been
reworked for season 5 - these include
cooldown and range changes to abilities
like gibraltars dome shield and blood
hounds I have the all-father
respectively but some of the most
significant changes are tied to caustics
gas canisters
they can't be triggered from the other
side of a door anymore and the gas won't
slow down caustics teammates GameSpot
has the complete list of legend changes
it's not just the characters that have
changed either Kings Canyon looks quite
different now
skull town and Thunderdome are gone with
a new location called Salvage along the
coast wetlands is also gone replaced by
the new capacitor additionally you'll
find new charge towers in Kings Canyon
activate
and any Legend standing on the platform
when the energy burst goes out will
instantly have their ultimate charged
and ready to go of course a new season
also means a new battle past
there's another 100 tiers of rewards to
unlock during season 5 along with an
all-new quest system quests are a whole
other story though so to learn more
about them or anything else in the
season 5 patch notes head to GameSpot
stay tuned for our Lobo guide to the
woozle sending out a decoy for the fools
old it's it works it rhymes